this is one of hundreds of thousands of
Volkswagen vehicles in the united states
affected by the emissions scandal mark
hartman bought his VW golf from a dealer
in maryland last summer when his
daughter was born he wanted an
environmentally friendly and economical
family car but when he heard that VW
falsified its emission values he didn't
want to drive it anymore we saw that the
president of Volkswagen mr. Horne said
that it was going to take over a year to
fix all the cars I don't want to be
putting out that kind of pollution over
the next year I don't want my daughter
being exposed to that kind of thing over
the next year and honestly I just don't
trust Volkswagen anymore consumer
advocate Dan Becker heads an
environmental group that targets the
auto industry many VW customers have
sought his advice the consumers were
lied to by VW they need to be firm they
need to say what they want they can get
their vehicle fixed but it should be
completely fixed so it doesn't pollute
any more not just replace the software
for those consumers for whom that isn't
acceptable they should demand a full
refund at the original purchase price
and then they can go by a different car
that doesn't pollute so much from a
company that doesn't lie as much mark
hartman decided to fight for
compensation he had paid nearly thirty
thousand dollars for his golf and twice
asked for his money back from the dealer
in nearby Gaithersburg to no avail here
he set out to try again
I'd like to go in and and have a
conversation with them the been
disrespectful to me I don't feel like
they've told me the truth but you know
this is this is kind of a last
opportunity to to deal with this outside
of court we are not allowed to show the
dealer's angry reaction he threatened to
sue us and again mark Hardman got no
results after a few minutes he was sent
away and told to contact VW headquarters
I'm pretty cynical about how they would
treat me I mean I knew they wouldn't
take the car back they should it's the
right thing to do but but for them it's
about making money and for Volkswagen
it's about making money so now I have to
talk to a judge and get a judge to roll
in the case Hartman filed his lawsuit as
one of the first of hundreds of
compensation claims against VW US courts
will be occupied with the emissions
cheating scandal for some time to come